just months to go until the tokyo
olympics the vast majority of the
population there
doesn't want them to go ahead this
summer japan has been setting records
for
daily new covered cases and the public
does fear that the games will only make
matters worse
[Music]
i don't think it can be done in a safe
environment this coming summer
in a very uneasy situation i hope it can
be postponed
it's scary to do it in the current
situation
[Music]
i can understand the efforts of the
athlete so i'd like to say i agree
in favor of that however after all this
time i don't think it would be good to
spread the infection of coronavirus
further
and since the state of emergency was
announced in osaka and tokyo
i think it's a bit contradictory now
i am for holding the games i hope they
will hold the olympics after taking
sufficient measures against infections
after all i think people are cheered up
by the olympics
[Music]
you